c'est une faute c'est une faute nous
venons de publier un rapport très clair
ici au sénat sur un objectif de 2% qui
correspond aux engagements du président
de la république pendant sa campagne
électorale du pays bas et deux pour cent
les dénonçons et argent en cela cette
course absolument et donc cela veut dire
grosso modo que il faut faire un bond de
2 milliards en par an pour atteindre cet
objectif mais il faut voir d'abord que
nous avons plus de trente mille hommes
aujourd'hui engagés dans des opérations
extérieures ce sont des opérations
extrêmement difficile qui sont
épuisantes avec des équipes qui n'ont
pas toujours les moyens de leur combat
et donc il y as sur le plan matériel
comme sur le plan moral
la nécessité de soutenir nos amis et
surtout de leur donner les moyens de nos
ambitions
parce que le pire c'est de leur donner
beaucoup d'ambition et peu de moyens
donc si on ne réduit les moyens
réduisons les zambiens ont réduit les
moyens ce quelqu'un est ce qu on réduit
la sécurité ce qu'on met en péril la
sécurité de la france en tout cas il est
clair qu'on sera obligé de réduire des
opérations extérieures et la sécurité et
met donc mais donc la sécurité parce que
si on est engagée c'est pour notre
sécurité et donc si on réduit notre
engagement c'est quand on réduit notre
sécurité
donc je pense qu'il y a là un certain
nombre de sujets qui doivent être
débattues je pense que il s'agit là de
près annonce que nous aurons des
discussions mais nous avons entendu la
ministre des armées à la commission du
sénat la semaine dernière je pense
qu'elle est déterminée à se battre dans
la ligne de ce que sont les conseils
d'un peu plus de dix engagements du
président et donc je pense que là le
comme d'habitude bercy lance ses
premières salves de manière à un avenir
tout le monde qu'il faut penser aux
économies et puis nous allons avoir un
certain nombre de négociations
moi ce que je dis c'est qu'un
gouvernement ne peut pas demander à ses
soldats
un niveau d'intervention aussi forte que
maintenant
sans leur donner les moyens de ses
interventions
est-ce que vous en est ce que vous en
appeler solennellement au président de
la république et le chef des armées pour
lui dire ne touchez pas au budget
la sécurité nationale française nous
avons été voir le président de la
république pour lui donner nos
propositions et nous avons cru
comprendre qu'il avait une réaction
positive à nos propositions nous sommes
dans un processus qui vient de s'engager
nous voterons le budget à la fin de
l'année 2010 est donc il y a encore des
négociations donc je ne mets pas le
couteau sous la gorge à quiconque
aujourd'hui mais je dis que clairement
nous ne pouvons pas donner à nos soldats
des missions sans leur donner les moyens
de ses missions